- [Kelly] Have a seat.
- [Seal] Thank you.
- Oh my God, I love your outfit.
- Thank you.
- Those are the pants
I love 'cause you can
just go (mimics explosion)
and they're off.
- You can?
- Yeah. Those are the button ones, right?
You know, like the
button ones on the sides
like when you play sports.
Anyway, I love those. It's
nice to see you again.
- Nice to see you again, yeah.
- We haven't seen each other,
I think we met and we were doing something
with David Foster for-
- That was it. Something he roped us into.
- And we showed up, but we,
it was a race situation that
we both knew a lot about.
- Can you remember the
song we were singing?
What were we singing?
- I don't.
It wasn't like "The Star Spangled Banner"
or anything, was it?
- No.
- No?
It wasn't something...
'Cause they do that at
some of those events.
- Yeah. It was good fun though.
- Totally, it was
memorable for both of us.
We can't remember what we sang.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
It was so long ago.
I mean like, probably 2004 or 5.
- Yeah, probably.
At least 16, 17 years ago.
- Yeah, it was a while back.
Anyway, your voice is incredible.
I was so honored to get to sing with you.
I love, there's people that can sing,
like, I feel like I'm a singer,
but you have, you're like a stylist.
You have that tone that
everybody recognizes
right off the bat, you know?
It's so special.
- You're not so bad yourself.
- Well, your tone though
is just incredible.
Do you remember the first time
you ever performed anywhere?
Like when you were a kid?
- Yeah. I remember the
first time singing live.
I had this teacher at
school called Mr. Ren.
And I idolized him and
I wanted to be like him.
He was the kind of teacher
that all the guy teachers
wanted to be and all the girl
teachers wanted to be with,
that kind of guy, you know?
If we're lucky in our lives,
we all have that one person
that sees us, you know?
And he saw me and he sang.
And I wanted to be just like him.
- That's so cool.
- So I started singing, then
he would encourage me to sing
and he'd put me on stage to
sing a song by Johnny Nash
at the Parents and Teachers
Association Evening.
Now, my parents had never
heard me sing before.
They didn't even know that I sang.
And I remember him calling
my name to the stage.
He said, "And now we're
gonna have young Seal
and he is gonna sing
this Johnny Nash song."
"I Can See Clearly." You know that?
♪ I can see clearly now the rain is gone ♪
♪ It's gonna be bright
bright sunshiny day ♪
- Such a great song.
- So he goes-
- Feel free to do that at any
moment during this interview.
It sounds so sexy. It's so cool.
It is. Your rasp.
(audience cheers)
You know what it is?
When I'm tired, like I'm tired today,
but when I'm tired I love
singing when I'm tired
'cause I feel like I
can sound cool like you
or like, maybe Toni Braxton.
You know that low raspy, just like,
I don't have that most of the time.
Keep going. So sorry.
How did you do with the
song when you were a kid?
Were you nervous on the stage?
- Yeah, I was.
I remember him calling me,
and it's like that scene in a movie where,
you know, everything goes silent
and you can hear a pin drop, you know,
'cause it was acapella and no one
had ever heard me sing
before, so I remember-
- You didn't even sing with
music for the first time?
- No, no.
- [Kelly] Bold.
- So he called me on stage
and I remember standing there
and looking out and seeing
everyone in the audience
pretty much like I'm seeing you except
there were more of you.
And I just, I wanted
the stage to just open
and swallow me up, you know?
It was the last place I wanted
to be and I was kind of like
I was frozen, but somehow
I closed my eyes and got
through it and sang
and kept my eyes closed
at the end of it.
And then just everyone applauded
and I remember looking out and seeing
my parents going (claps).
- (laughs) Like, what?
- And the interesting thing
about that experience is,
is that that place,
that stage that felt
like the most terrifying,
most lonely place all of
a sudden felt like home.
And I never forgot that feeling.
So I guess throughout my
life, I did different things
until I eventually decided I
was gonna commit to singing.
But I never forgot that feeling.
And I always knew that I
would come back to that.
- I love that story.
But I also love that you
pointed out it is like
if one person sees you and you're younger
and it gives you confidence
that you can do something
and maybe you're special
and every kid likes to
feel special, right?
- Of course.
- It does take one
person, I think to like,
I mean it's good if it's more than one,
but if it's just one
that's nice that, you know,
you feel like you maybe found something
that you're special at.
That's what happened to me too.
- And you're absolutely right-
- It changes your personality, everything.
- Yeah, it really comes
down to who, you know,
that champion or those champions
in your life that do see
you and encourage you
to be special.
And who knows, if not for Mr. Ren,
perhaps, you know, it
wouldn't have happened for me.
I certainly wouldn't
have had that experience.
And throughout my life I've
had timely people who have
come and championed me and
have seen me in different ways
and given me the inspiration
and the courage to move on
which is why I feel so
strongly about mentoring.
- Yeah.
- I found out fairly recently that as much
as I love singing and as
much as I love performing
and as much as music is a part of my life,
I really love coaching.
I would much rather see somebody
else transcend whatever's
holding them back than doing it myself.
I get more pleasure out of that.
- That's why I love being
a part of "The Voice."
'Cause it's like every,
and especially 'cause I
came from that environment,
like it's the most awesome
thing to be blessed
in your career.
A lot of people can sing, a lot
of people can do what we do.
Don't have your tone, but like, you know,
a lot of people can do what we do,
and it's cool to be able to look
at someone younger and go,
"Let me show you what
maybe you're not seeing,
that little light in you."
And it's so cool to be able
to bring that out of people.
It is so gratifying.
All right, so your biggest
song "Kiss from a Rose"
was from your sophomore album,
which usually is kind of a
tough album for everybody,
but this is like your biggest
song on your sophomore album.
That's incredible.
- Thank you.
- It's an incredible thing.
- I got really lucky.
I got really, really lucky
because as you say, you know,
we call it the sophomore jinx,
the second album generally tanks
especially if you've had a big first album
which in my case I did.
Anyway, came to recording the second,
or releasing the second album.
We released four singles from it,
I think it was "Prayer for the Dying,"
"Newborn Friend," "Show Me"
and this weird little song
called "Kiss from a Rose."
And I remember the song
"Kiss from a Rose,"
it charted at number
60, dropped to number 80
the next week and was done.
It was out of the charts.
I did this terrible video
for it, which didn't help.
(audience laughs)
And the song was done.
I was in the studio
recording the third album.
Now the first album had sold I think
about 7 million or thereabouts, you know,
which in those days it was pretty big.
- Now it's unheard of.
People don't buy albums.
- But even then it was pretty successful.
And so it had sold about 7 million albums.
The second, after the
release of those four singles
I just mentioned, sold
about two and a half.
And it was like, okay-
- Which is still great.
- It wasn't bad.
It wasn't quite the
success of the first one.
But, you know, we were licking our wounds
and back in the studio
making a third album.
And then I got a call from
someone called Joel Schumacher.
- Just someone, yeah.
- God rest his soul, you know.
And he said, "Look, Seal, I'm a huge fan.
I'm making this movie
called "Batman Forever"
and I need a song for the love scene
between Kidman and
Kilmer," I think it was.
"Have you got anything?"
My manager, Cavallo, Bob Cavallo,
was on the phone at the time.
He said, "Have you got anything?"
I said, "Well, Joel, no I don't.
I've finished promoting the second album.
I released the singles. I'm sorry."
So Cavallo says, "Let
me take care of this."
So he sends Joel Schumacher
a copy of my second album
and puts a little asterisk
next to "Kiss from a Rose."
The next day Joel calls back, he says,
"I temped the song in the scene.
It doesn't work. Okay.
But I love the song so much,
I'm just gonna stick it
on the end credits."
So, you know, 8 million
albums and four Grammys later,
everyone's like, well, you know-
- Oh my God! But you know what?
I love this story
because a lot of artists,
like, we always get told,
like I always tell artists too,
that I work with on "The Voice,"
it's like, don't listen to all the chatter
all the time, just do what you're doing.
It's gonna hit or it's not,
or you never know it's gonna
happen because it's just
timing sometimes, you know?
- So I owe so much to, you
know, talk about champions
and people seeing you.
It could be argue that I owe my career
to Joel Schumacher, the
late Joel Schumacher.
- And you're manager for
that little asterisk.
Being like, "Thank you,
you should listen to this."
You're also touring.
Tell us about the new tour.
Like what's new, what can people expect?
- Okay, well it's a 30 year anniversary
of the first two albums.
So the song that I'll sing tonight is,
that was some 30 years ago.
And so what we've decided to do is to go
out and sing those two albums back
to back in their kind of studio form.
And when I say studio, I
mean that the person who
is as much a part of my,
what people perceive to be my sound,
my producer Trevor Horn,
he's actually MDing the tour.
And he's never done that before.
So he'll be the musical
director on the tour.
So you'll hear those songs,
anyone who has those early albums
and a bunch of memories attached to them-
- Nostalgia for sure.
- They'll be able to kind of relive
that experience again with Trevor Horn.
- [Kelly] Collaborative process though,
you came back to that.
- Exactly.
- All right, we have to do another break
but you can see Seal on tour this spring.
So go online for dates y'all.
And look for the re-release
and deluxe edition of "Seal."
It's out now.